foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
you get indictment you get an indictment
you get an indictment
of the Trump fraudulent fake electors
from Michigan are charged with felonies
carrying up to 14 years per felony
in the state of Michigan now
do you remember this happening I
remember this I remember seeing videos
of these fake fraudulent Trump electors
trying to get into the capital of
Michigan this is why they're charged
with with forgery
reason why is because they forged
an official state document
see in the state of Michigan it's a
little different than other states and
their laws
the electors
have to actually convene at the Capitol
you see it's in the it's in the law so
when you when you actually
certify the electors it has to say
that they were certified at the Capitol
well they weren't at the Capitol they
weren't allowed to end the capital
that's why they weren't
we know that they that they convened
outside the capitol there's video they
took the video of themselves
I mean did you expect these fraudulent
fake electors to be the most intelligent
people on Earth they're moglodytes
they're Trump supporters they're real
America First Nazis they tried to
overthrow the government these
nincompoop Nazis
of course
of course they're not the most brilliant
people on the face of the Earth my
question is
this is my question did Genie Thomas
have contact with these specific
State electors that's what I want to
know
I think that's a question that everyone
should want to know
wouldn't you like to know if the Supreme
of Supreme Court Justice's wife who is a
q Anon believer
who probably had some sort of sway when
it comes to certain decisions oink oink
oink
up there at the highest court on the of
the land
wouldn't you like to know because she
she was really stumping for these fake
State electors
in Arizona and in Michigan she was
emailing people apparently
so not not only Not only was she talking
to them she was doing it on record with
like time dates and stamps and [__]
so I I mean that's just a question I
think that someone should ask probably
at the federal level
rather Clarence Thomas's wife Jeannie
meant Q Anon Nut Job had contact with
these 16 State electors and I'm going to
show you video today of them trying to
get into the Capitol and I'm going to
try to see if we can see the video that
they recorded of themselves uh fake
certifying these electors right
I told you I don't know a couple months
ago I was like you know this funny
Willis thing you know she indicts people
down in Georgia it's probably going to
open up the floodgates for Michigan
Pennsylvania Wisconsin and Arizona
hmm
yeah you can always count on me can't
you why not
so um I don't want to avoid this I'm a
small town guy I'm from an actual small
town a little bitty town
it's about 4 000 people
the town that I'm from I actually grew
up outside the town we didn't grow up in
the town it was outside the town
I grew up on a farm
just near the Lake of the Ozarks in
Missouri
a lot of small town folks where I'm from
mainly folks that look like
me
there's a new Jason Aldean song out I
read the lyrics a little bit yesterday I
did not get a chance to listen to the
song
I did see that CMT is pulling
the music video
I did listen to most of the song this
morning now I'm a country I'm a country
music lover as well you all know this
Lord I'm from the country of course I
like country music
this morning I saw that Sheryl Crow
weighed in on the Jason Aldean song
and Cheryl Crow
um you know she she put it pretty good
and a lot of people are pointing to the
racism in the song and the dog whistles
in the song now to me I'm from rural
Missouri rule white Missouri my
experience is Rule white Missouri okay
that is my experience
that is the world that I know that I
viewed my world from
it's like the foundation of my
experience being from a small white
rural town
unlike Jason Aldean apparently I guess
Jason Aldean is from a town of like 200
000 people or something that's that's
not a small town Jason and I think he
lives in Nashville also not a small town
Jason the [__] does he know about small
towns
first off now I will say that this song
does have dog whistles in it 100 I'm
convinced it adds dog whistles in the
video and in the lyrics and the reason
why is because all the racists are
really excited about the song and they
love it and they love the parts about
the song that you would think oh that
might be a dog whistle they're like
that's the best part of the song
yeah we know why because you're a
[__] bigot
now Jason Aldean has the absolute right
to release this song this stupid [__]
honestly it's not that great of a song
it's kind of stupid
it sucks I'm not that much into re you
know newer country music I'm into like
80s 90s Prime Country Gold Country even
older than that so I'm not much into new
country music in the first place so it
takes a lot to impress me with the new
country music song to be quite honest
you sound kind of like pop not like
country they're Jason you [__] idiot
now Jason Aldean and his wife are very
outspoken about their political beliefs
they're trumpers they're Maga they're q
and honors that's right I said it [__]
them
so it's not surprising that Jason Aldean
would pick a song like this to record
and release I apparently he didn't write
this song which is not surprising I
don't know if you've listened to Jason
and his wife speak but I don't know if
they could [__] write a goddamn
grocery list let alone a [__] country
music song
Jason Aldean has lost a lot of his
audience base over the years because he
is a bigot
I know people personally who used to
like Jason Aldean who don't now because
he's a [__] racist
but when you record a song and you
release the song and you're like no it's
not a dog whistle it's not racist but
all the racists are like that's the best
racist song I've ever heard of I mean
you're literally shooting it in front of
a courthouse that the only thing the
courthouse is known for is a race riot
that's where you filmed it you're
filming you're filming protest you're
filming protest
when the cops when the cops make it to
where the protests get violent
you're singing you're singing and saying
lyrics
about your guns and how you're gonna
kill people that you don't like in your
town
sounds really welcoming almost like a
small town wouldn't be let me tell you
something I you know again I [__]
grew up in a small town
rule white Missouri I'm not trying to
[__] change or or Gaslight or [__]
whitewash my experience it was white
it was racist it was bigoted it's an
institution of white supremacy I know
that
because I don't know I I grew up and got
a brain and had some thoughts
read some [__] read a book or two Jason
and figured out that um all that [__]
that I was taught as a kid is all a
bunch of [__] and they taught it to
me for a specific reason
the reason why Jason's singing
number one
almost the majority per capita of gun
violence in this country happens in
small towns
you're much safer in a big city or a
larger Town than you are a small town
number one small towns in this country
are are ripe with poverty I don't know
if you know that I don't know if you
know that Jason that's probably probably
Jason doesn't know that because Jason
isn't from a small town he's not from
one
but the thing that pisses me off about
this song the most
is is over the last two three decades
they've perpetuated this white gun
culture I can't speak to the racism and
the dog whistles in the song by my
experience I can definitely call them
out and show them to you and I'm going
to show you the evidence that absolutely
this song is [__] racist because the
racists love it
and they love it because it's racist
so I mean you cannot call it racist
you'd be like oh the words you didn't
say black people anywhere in the song he
doesn't say racist words in the song
Cranston Steen you [__] I don't
know who I don't know if it was Brian or
Ed one of those [__] brothers and I
I'm Gonna Get You yeah you're gonna be
on the show I met you on the show before
and you've been welcome here but you're
[__] nonsense about this song
you know better you know better
[__] this both sides and [__] oh
man I'm getting sick and tired of that
[__]
sick and [__] tired of Brian and Ed
both sides and [__]
I don't I don't see any racist lyrics
show them to me show me the racist
lyrics
look at the video man look at the music
video
you can turn the [__] sound off on
the music video and understand what the
hell he's saying
and if you're not you're if you're not
capable enough of going and doing that
before you call this song not racist
I mean you can read the lyrics some
people aren't going to want to listen to
this song number one it's dog [__] it is
a dog [__] song
and it's not surprising that it Rose to
number one
because all these manga Knights are like
oh yeah yeah let's go oh they're calling
it racist let's go see how racist it is
yeah we love this racist song
I mean is it surprising that it Rose to
number one
I know I wanted to talk about the fecal
lengthers today but I really think I
have a duty to talk about this
and the reason why is because I am small
town America
I actually believe that's why I connect
well with the audience
I believe that I believe that that the
all Shucks American towns still exist
that culture is still there somewhere
hiding
hiding amongst the pile of vile bigotry
and racism and and trumpism and
authoritarianism this this longing to
have one person save you from everything
that oh man if you got a problem a gun
will fix it because that's what the
song's about
the song is about if you don't like
someone and you don't like something
you can just shoot and kill it that's
what you can do
now it's not surprising that this song
written about small towns and white gun
culture because as I see it that's what
the song's written about now because
it's written about white gun culture it
inherently you know they gotta sell it
to a bunch of racists so they gotta put
that racism right there in there right
that's those dog whistles
that racist songs when I grew up just
said it right outright not So Much
Anymore
they want to sell it on the big stage
right
but this Jason Aldean song
to me the lyrics
specifically the lyrics not the song the
song is [__] the music is [__] the music
video is racist as [__]
but the lyrics in particular
describe white gun culture that I have
told you about for the last two and a
half years that exist in this country
it's the main issue that we have with
gun violence mass shootings people
shooting and killing each other people
having guns that shouldn't have [__]
Guns White gun culture and a lot of
people give me [__] you're like you
[__] you race Trader I'm not no
[__] race Trader when I was a kid we
had guns in our house in our farmhouse
we didn't we didn't use them for
protection against nobody dummy we
didn't lock the [__] doors to our
house we didn't lock the [__] keys to
our car that were in our driveway we
didn't lock the we we didn't take the
keys out of the car or the equipment
tractors whatever the hell it was
we didn't have enemies we didn't see the
guns as protecting ourselves from the
government or enemies
that was not the the feeling in our
house around our guns that's not what
was talked about with the guns the guns
were used to hunt
deer turkey
we use guns to get rid of varmin
raccoons
possums we had chickens possums we eat
the [__] out of your eggs and kill your
chickens
and we had a you know occasional pellet
gun you know to have fun with birds and
squirrels
it's target practice
but nowhere nowhere in our culture in my
house and my family in our town were the
guns to kill other people because
they're our enemy
or to protect ourselves from the
government that's that wasn't a thing
I hate to [__] break it to you brain
dead 2A Bros who live in the city by the
way most you [__] don't even
live in small towns like Jason Aldean
you [__] you pose an ass little
[__] and the [__] fake ass tough guy
thing all that [__] pisses me off
more than anything else about this
[__] song when they refer to
themselves as [__] tough guys look
where I come from in a small town a
[__] tough guy walking around talking
about how tough he is would get his
[__] teeth knocked in
yeah talking all kinds of [__]
how he's gonna kill this person and kill
that person you'd get your [__] face
stomped in
and by the way speaking of stomping
speaking of stomping that's one of the
things that he goes on about in this
song about how you stomp and burn the
flag what's your [__] right
it's your [__] right to Stomp and
burn that flag [__]
it's your [__] constitutional right
that's the problem with this [__] gun
culture this white gun culture
and yes it is a white gun culture
they think they can do whatever the [__]
they want to do whenever the [__] they
want to do it because they're white and
they got guns
cause you got a problem if you got a
problem if you got a problem and you're
white in America oh if you got a problem
gonna fix it
I'm telling you especially if you're a
white dude in America gonna fix it
look at it
look at some of the shootings look at
some of the [__] violence
you you think the majority of gun
violence per capita happens in cities
get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense
you're not paying attention
people are shot and killed every [__]
day
in rural areas where do you think the
majority of school shootings happen
the majority of school shootings happen
in rural areas
this is bone-headed type stuff
that we look at this Aldine song number
one I know
I I actually think that this canceling
him or whatever the [__] it is
are bitching about the lyrics of this
song
actually gives him a bigger platform to
[__] sing it on
but here we are that's why I didn't
[__] bring it up yesterday I was
hoping it would go right underneath the
[__] dustpan
of [__] is what I was hoping now
couldn't nap the internet wouldn't let
me
again I don't get the [__] I don't
get to make up what's going on
I just comment on it
that's that's my job
is the comment on what the hell is
happening
and Jason Aldean has made this song and
and his racist ass supporters if you
don't think if you don't think [__]
if you think that this song isn't racist
you haven't seen who's supporting it and
who's really excited about this song
this song is [__] it's [__] [__] it's
not even objectively a good song like
when you listen to it you're like yeah
that's all right
like the music if you took the lyrics
out and got rid of the video right I'd
say you just hum the lyric she didn't
say the lyrics and you listened to the
music it's [__]
it's not even a it's not even a I mean
it's no friends in low places
it's not
it's not a George Strait song it's
definitely not a [__] Alan Jackson
song no [__] no hails to the no
I mean [__] you could even make the case
that Alabama the band Alabama when they
would use the rebel flag because they're
because their name is Alabama on all
their on all their [__] their t-shirts
their [__] their CDs you know back
then I don't think they used the rebel
flag anymore you could say well that
shit's kind of racist but if you go
listen to the song of Alabama like this
the lyrics to the song
you're not gonna believe that for more
than two seconds
but Alabama's got good [__] music the
music is good
this music is [__]
I don't know if that's exactly why
Sheryl Crow's like ah [__] this [__] I'm
gonna come out against this but Sheryl
Crow to be fair Sheryl Crow is from a
small town
she is from a small town and her point
was is like look small towns generally
aren't [__] it's not like a a violent
culture in small towns
but it has become that way
in some small towns
I told you the story of my small town
now
my small town we speaking of the rebel
flag in my small town in White America
I didn't I mean there were some people
that had like the the Confederate flag
right and people people would wear stuff
with the Confederate flag but it wasn't
it wasn't like a
it wasn't like a thing around our town
that everyone oh man everyone's got the
Confederate flag on it really wasn't a
thing right and the reason why is
because where
um where we our town is
it it was actually for the union for the
most part in that part of the country
because there wasn't a lot of Farmland a
little bit but not a lot we weren't
growing cotton a lot in in the mountains
in the Ozark Mountains
you just weren't growing much cotton in
the mountains
you need you need some more fertile
ground which in Missouri I don't know if
you know that in Missouri the northern
half of Missouri is all the Farmland
above the north of the Missouri River
that's where all the the fertile land is
it kind of looks like Iowa well it's
like Iowa 2.0 kind of thing right
before you get there but everything
south of the Missouri River is really
[__] hilly and Rocky as [__] because
that's the that's the foothills of the
Ozark Mountains
so there's not a lot of crop so during
the Civil War I can't even believe I got
a [__] do Civil War history for the
Jason Aldean sense out there Jesus
Christ you [__]
people need to read a goddamn book Jason
Aldean fans okay so during the Civil War
a lot of people don't know this in
Missouri it was flip-flopped because of
that the north the northern part of
Missouri were actually Southern
sympathizers
the southern part of Missouri where
Northern sympathizers kind of weird kind
of weird
right
that's why you have the Kansas and
Missouri
uh a feud is because Northern Missouri
was South Kansas where where Northern
sympathy anyways the point is this is
there wasn't a lot of rebel flags where
I was
some people like the you know Dukes of
Hazard and General Lee the car again
some people wore it on their shirt some
people might have had it in their yards
but I don't remember it being this big
[__] cultural thing where everyone
worshiped the Confederate flag or that
we thought we were from the south we
definitely did not think we were from
the [__] South where I was from
in Central Missouri
but now when you drive to the Lake of
the Ozarks on Highway 54 which is the
main artery on the Saint Louis side of
the Lake of the Ozarks
okay
on this on the St Louis side so the east
side of the Lake of the Ozarks there's a
highway called highway 54. it's a
four-lane highway it's the main artery
that goes down through that part of the
state
it is the the highway that gets you to
the Lake of the Ozarks if you're
interested in going yeah maybe you
should go maybe you shouldn't I don't
know
but when you're driving down the highway
there is and I've told you this before
I've done a tick tock on it years ago
there's a big huge flagpole this son of
a [__] has got to be 80 foot tall
just sticking out of the middle of
nowhere right out by the highway
there's no house no building there's
nothing there just a [__] flagpole
with the stars and bars on it
with the Confederate flag the
Confederate Battle Flag
on this flagpole crazy part is
is it's right up to the boundary to the
highway on this piece of this thin piece
of land where there's no house or
anything like that
they had electric an electric pole
installed on the property
they have a fence around the flag with
cameras on the [__] fence and the
flag
because they know why the they know what
could happen because why the flag is
there
the flag is there as a statement not
because they're proud
it's a statement
stay away from our town
you people who aren't us meaning people
who aren't White
that's the statement it's hate it's hate
[__] it's hate and Jason Aldean
with these lyrics describing a small
town in this way with this white gun
culture the way I see it again it's my
experience I see it that way but when
you watch the video and you will see who
is supporting it you'll know yeah it's
got It's got the dog whistles of racism
in it the show
you'll know that Jason Aldean's song is
the same message that that Confederate
battle flag on the 80-foot Pole right
outside my hometown is sending you are
not welcome here
that's what the song is you're not
welcome here
and they think it's some sort of [__]
song that's that's warm-hearted and that
describes small towns in a great way
what that you're not welcoming the
people
and you wonder why Rhonda santis Donald
Trump and all these [__] sludge ass
Nazi Republicans are running around the
country
demonizing diversity equity and
inclusion you people are [__] dumb as
dog [__] when you don't see that that's
what this song is about
who do you think Jason Aldean is singing
to huh
huh who do you think his [__] fans
are at this point
him and his [__] trumped-up wife you
think oh they're all over [__] social
media they [__] oh God damn they love
them some hate they [__] love them
some hate
who do you think their fans are huh
So when you say the song isn't racist
you're just wanting it not to seem
racist by and just doing the dog
whistles here changing these words
around here making it to where you know
who we're talking about when we're
saying you're not welcome wink wink wink
wink black people that's what I mean
wink wink
so get the [__] out of here when you
cannot tell me that this song is not big
at it and racist
[__] you
because I damn well sure know being from
a small town unlike Jason Aldean
I damn well sure know what's how small
towns are how small towns have thought
in the past and definitely how they're
bigoted asses are thinking now and Jason
Aldean and whoever wrote this song and
whoever produced this [__] video and
had the idea to do the video the way
they did it
absolutely 100 knew exactly
exactly who Jason Aldean's audience is
well they're not my audience I you know
they should come here and learn a
[__] thing or two every Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch do
not forget to subscribe to the YouTube
channel
God damn I talk for a while on that I
didn't know I was all the way to the
bottom of the hour holy [__] I really
wasn't paying attention to the clock on
that one
I'm just letting her sling you know what
I mean yeah I knew I had to address as
Jason Aldean thing I really want to talk
about the electors and Trump's the the
you know his interview last night and
all the sludge that he puked up on stage
with Sean Hannity but I couldn't ignore
it anymore I I got to do my duty that is
something I must do is speak out
especially when I know about something I
feel like I have the obligation to the
audience to be authentic about my
feeling about the Jason Aldean song
so there it is I don't know if you want
to go tell people what I think but if
you do share it around on Facebook I
guess at the Tony Michaels you can find
us live there every single day you can
watch us every single day there live you
can also follow me on Twitter and we're
gonna go through a couple of the uh
Jason Aldean simps today I'm gonna show
you I'm gonna show you the evidence that
you need that you need
to show that y'all uh oh oh well the the
races see the dog whistles so they must
be there yeah they're there also follow
us on Twitch if you can it's free to
follow us on Twitch also don't forget if
you have your Amazon Prime account
linked to your Twitch account resub
give us a resub over there on Twitch if
you don't resub every month we don't get
the the couple bucks that Amazon gives
us so if you have linked your Amazon
Prime account to your Twitch account for
us go to twitch.tv Tony Michaels and
re-subscribe if you need directions on
how to link your account or how to
resubscribe just go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you'll find the link there
with the directions on how to link the
two it's the fourth one now
it says link Amazon and twitch
and those are the directions there to to
link them and to resub every single
month
and I think every single one of you for
doing that it's really it's really a
great way to monetarily support the show
without spending extra money if you got
a Prime account you can support the show
without getting any extra money
I don't know do you think we're gonna
get do you think we're gonna see uh
trials for these 16 electors I don't
know maybe they were asking for pardons
too maybe maybe they weren't I don't
know is Jeannie Thomas in contact with
them we'll find out don't go anywhere
we're gonna get to the bottom of this
right after this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
thank
[Music]
me I'll always give my opinion hell most
time you might not like it when I get my
opinion but I don't give a [__]
I don't give a [__]
I don't give a [__] Deb says Tony
speaking from the heart as always
as always I try to be truly authentic
and I couldn't I just couldn't ignore
this stupid [__] song Anymore
I couldn't
um someone says here on YouTube don't
care about this stupid song yeah I don't
either
I don't give a [__] about it I don't
care if C CN CMT takes it off the air I
don't give a [__] if he holds concerts I
don't give a [__] I care [__] less
about Jason Aldean I don't give two
[__]
the problem is
is that you give fuel to the Nazi fire
sometimes when you do this stuff
and I couldn't ignore it anymore I just
I couldn't
I've been I I've I thought about it
yesterday read the lyrics yesterday I
didn't even listen to the song yesterday
because I'm like yeah [__] Jason
Aldean's horrible anyways what the [__]
do I care about this song I read the
lyrics and I'm like yeah you know the
lyrics sound like there's dog whistles
in there and then I read reports about
the music video I didn't actually watch
the music video I read reports about
what's in the music video
and I was like yeah well [__]
so I couldn't I couldn't ignore this
anymore
so it is it is what it is as far as the
song goes because Jason Aldean here
again and Jason Aldean has the right to
produce and release whatever racist
songs that he wants to produce and
release I don't know if you if you know
who David Allen Coe is David Allen Cohen
is a very controversial country music
singer he has a lot of good songs but he
has some songs on his albums that are
absolutely [__] racist
talking about comparing comparing black
people to to to animals talking about
hanging black people with and calling
them the hard R in the song like back in
the day back in the day when they made
racist songs they didn't [__] dog
whistle that [__] they just outright did
it
a just outright [__] did it
so Jason Aldean is no [__] tough guy
here I mean come on man
if you're if you're gonna sing a song
like this come on get come on get with
it man come on just say what you want to
[__] say man I'm so tired of these
[__] running around wanting to
say the n-word with the hard R and not
doing it right
knees lyrics and having these music
videos and going oh my song's not racist
it's about small town people
small town white people and only white
people being in that town I mean if you
read the song it says that if you come
in our town we'll [__] kill you my
grandpa's gun because that's what we do
in a small town we don't put up with
your ass I mean literally what the [__]
it it's what it's saying if you [__]
go listen to it or read the [__]
lyrics Jason grow a set of balls you
[__] [__] and just say the word just
say the word you [__] [__]
produce music that is overtly racist you
[__] slug do it oh that's right you
won't do it you won't do it
because what you want is your racism to
be all [__] hidden up with dog
whistles so that way you can say it's
not racist you're just trying to cancel
me people don't like me cause I'm white
[__] out of here people don't like you
because you're a [__]
that's why people don't like you and his
wife too [__] his wife too [__] her
she's a racist piece of [__] too
both of them [__] on social
media saying crazy ass [__]
I love how they're crying that you can't
cancel country music do you remember
when the Dixie Chicks now they're just
known as the chicks
when they got on stage and said [__]
George Bush basically do you remember
that oh [__] they would they wouldn't
play those [__] on the radio oh
my God they [__] canceled them
country music canceled those
[__]
oh my God
just cancel them
straight [__] cancel them
but when Jason Aldean gets canceled oh
my God it's the worst day in the entire
world that they pulled this that they
pulled this video
from from CMT
the chicks got their entire albums
canceled they wouldn't play their music
videos on TV they wouldn't play their
[__] songs on the radio they
blacklisted them
because they said their opinion they
didn't sing some [__] song about
shooting and killing anyone who isn't
one of them coming to their town that
ain't what they that's not what they
[__] sing a song about that they just
said their opinion on stage [__] George
Bush
I mean I don't remember the exact words
something like that but it was basically
[__] George Bush
and they cancel them straight [__] it
was after 9 11 and they straight [__]
canceled them all the way across the
board it didn't matter what their song
was about
and they have a song they have a chicks
have a great song called the uh Earl had
to die
I'm be
I'm beginning to think that they miss
they mislabeled and titled that song and
I don't think it was Earl had to die
maybe it was Jason I don't know okay
that's my last word on it yeah other
than [__] Jason Aldean uh well you know
what let me show you here I want to show
you this one thing
um there's an account on Twitter and
they're just a [__] Q Anon racist
Trump
I I mean I don't even know how to just
the the name of the [__] account in
the wokeness is that gives you any kind
of [__] clue what kind of account
this is here is here's the in wokeness
um
post it says I stand with Jason Aldean
right
oh your ears Gabe Sanchez let me let me
get Gabe in on this I want to see what
he thinks okay so you've heard the Jason
Aldean stuff right
no I don't know if I have
[Music]
you have to live on [__] Mars not to
hear about this Jason Aldean thing hold
on hold on show me what it is order the
song oh oh yeah the CMT yeah oh yeah he
got canceled all right all right all
right now you're caught up see here's
here's the thing I'm not a country fan
so they all kind of like sound the same
slash look the same to me I am a country
fan and this country song like
objectively take the lyrics out of it
take the video out of it just the music
it's [__] it's [__] it's not that
good like I said it sounds it sounds
like every other [__] country pop
song right now it's the reason it's the
reason why I do like I'm just you know
there's like a handful of country songs
I'm like yeah I could I could you know
dance that whatever
don't don't play don't play don't play
that [__] you didn't know Garth Brooks
was that's pathetic whoa
okay so so here here's the thing is that
a lot of people are like oh it's
including the uh Brian and no no it was
Brian or Ed crane I saw Brian
that [__] and I I think we've
had Ed on the show not Brian I've been
invited Brian I've talked to Brian and
uh you know
if you know yeah exactly and the reason
they're doing that is because you're
getting paid by Elon because they get
paid for the comments which is an insane
concept I just want to point out when
you're already hemorrhaging money at a
company you've laid off 80 to 90 percent
of the staff you're unable to pay rent
in multiple locations you can't you
can't actually pay vendors for the
services that you that you need to run
your
um run your business which is this
platform that is Twitter and on top of
that all of that they're like yeah you
know what we're going to pay the
creators the some of the advertising
money that we need to keep things
running
it's hilarious that they're like look
pay me and I think will legate post he's
like I took my blue check back because
I'm gonna pay Elon like a hundred
dollars this year and he's gonna give me
10 000. like why wouldn't I take that
deal if I hate Elon like that's the best
thing I could do yeah and buy a blue
chick and then he has to pay me right in
in many ways it's like it does make
sense and you're kind of like oh [__]
you want to bleed if you want to bleed
him dry and you got a lot of replies you
got a lot of replies and you want to
bleed England right go buy a blue check
I'm telling you even even if even if
they he only pays you a thousand dollars
this year and you pay him a hundred it's
worth it because it takes money out of
his [__] piece there's a part of me
that's like oh man this like both sides
are like oh what do you guys think kind
of argument well I mean even if you just
have a lot of replies if you if you have
a large account with a lot of robot now
you can stoke the replies that's what
they're doing that's what Ed and Brian
are doing with this bull side [__] is
they're trying to stoke outrage in their
comments so they get more replies so
there's more ads dropped in the replies
but what I want to know
specifically is I've seen the payouts
that everyone's doing but I want to know
is that in total or is that the last
month or what is that well I don't know
but we're getting off track here I want
to get back yeah bring it back to the
Jason Aldean thing
now a lot of people including Brian is
like I don't see the racism in the
lyrics okay well the problem is and this
is what I always say about Republicans
Republicans may not see themselves as
Nazis but the Nazis
think that they're Nazis so that's kind
of the issue right so this song at first
glance and when you read the lyrics it
may not sound racist but the races think
it's racist yeah isn't the doesn't the
video show stuff from 2020 yes it shows
stuff from from George Floyd protests
and everything else
um but here here is end wokeness I don't
know if you oh yeah this oh yeah so can
you verify for me for sure on air here
that this this account is definitely a
[__] racist account yeah it's
definitely it's definitely a [__]
racist account okay okay so and and
you're gonna see it here this is
literally I know what this is from it's
[__] that CNN video this is the meme
this is the meme that they posted so you
see up here at the top it says fiery but
mostly peaceful this is acceptable Tony
who started those fires right well there
there has been there has been uh there
has been court cases on this and it was
right wait you're telling me that white
supremacists actually I'm just saying it
white supremacist started the fires in
Minneapolis
AutoZone fire the the Minneapolis PD
fire those are the people that were
behind it it's been literally proven but
you see this the skin color and the the
uh what what the top box here is trying
to portray this is black right that's
what they're saying this is black oh
look it's small small white town down
here uh Jason Aldean try that in a white
town oh look right in a small
non-diverse town try that in a small
white town
try that in a small white town that has
no people of color
but has more guns than people
right well but the thing is is that
they're getting the dog whistle here
this is the dog whistle in the song So
end woken is here he stands with Jason
Aldean because he hears that dog whistle
baby and I even said for anyone who is
saying the Jason Aldean song isn't about
race I give you my first Maga exhibit it
may sound like it's about race but it's
racist it may not sound like it's about
race but the race is sure to hear the
dog whistles listen if the if the racist
here the dog whistles
that's why it was written that way yeah
it's not complicated but [__] Jason
Aldean [__] his stupid [__] wife they're
ridiculous they're bigots they're
they're haters that's all they do is
they love to hate and you know they can
go to hell for all I can you know
I wish I wish Jason the best of luck the
other thing too is that Jason Aldean
isn't actually from a small town did you
see that he's from some town and
Jordan's got almost like 200 000 people
like that's not enough yeah I'm like
that's not a [__] small town you
[__] that's not even close to a
small town [__] I I was from a town of 4
000 people that's it that's all we had
in our town I went to a high school with
four thousand people exactly your high
school was our town was as big as your
[__] high school now I I lived in a
town of 4 000 people right but four
thousand forty five hundred it got
bigger you know as I get older and more
people moved in there and now more
people are moving out but the point is
this
is that even when I go like some place
where there's a town like 40 or 50 000
like this in the small town like no it
is I'm like no it's not and then some
people who look at me who grew up in a
town with like 300 people literally a
town they're like you didn't grow up in
a small town you grew up in the city
yeah what the [__] are you talking
they're like you had a McDonald's [__]
and a stoplight
[__] you grew up in a city I'm like nah
not really but yeah I see what you're
saying yeah like I think I think there
are objective right like cities and
towns you're like yeah that's a small
pop that's a small town right and then
there's relative where you've got
someone with 300 or 200 people and
they're like oh yeah no uh we are the
most uh minimal uh you know type of town
we have limited resources we barely get
this or we barely get that we're a small
town
um so I think when you get like when you
get into the foul like this Sub sub 10
000 you're like yeah it's a small town
that's a small town like objectively and
then when you start talking about people
who have less than a thousand or or a
thousand they're like no no no that's
not this is right so I think it's always
station and a post office [__] and the
post office is in the gas station yeah
okay that's how small art down like
they're literally that's towns a town
that my dad was from the [__] post
office was in the gas station like
that's where it was that's how small
that town was but I mean the the thing
is here is that um like for instance in
Missouri and there's a town down by uh
Branson Missouri it's Springfield
Missouri it's the third largest
metropolitan area in Missouri it's a
huge Trucking Hub it's right off I-44
which goes down to Oklahoma and goes up
to St Louis and so it's a huge Trucking
Hub uh Springfield Missouri is and it
has it has a small town feel and what I
mean by small town feel is there's a lot
of Evangelical white Christians there oh
yeah that's what gives it that small
town oink oink you know I yeah you get
what I'm saying the same type of people
who are like man can we just go back to
a time when things were simpler right
well we could just be men and women and
we didn't have to worry about these
pronouns and these genders or these
non-white people
like that's awesome I mean there were
there were non-white people then they
just knew their place that's what
they're talking about right yeah and
that's what the song is about is you
need to know your [__] place you're
not you don't belong in small white
America you belong in wherever the else
that is and you wonder why people who
who are not white are constantly looking
over their shoulder to be like is this
gonna be the day that I right end up in
in in in a hospital or or somebody does
something to me or like I look at
someone the wrong way like this isn't
like like
it's insane that you know
that we we as far as we've come
we we also haven't come that far in many
ways right and there are there are many
many white people who still believe I
think it was there's a video I think it
was on my Instagram or Tick Tock or
something like that it was like the
whitest you know the most racist town I
think it was I'll try to find it but
yeah it's in Arkansas is it the one
where the person's just like holding a
sign and people are driving through and
they're just yelling for vanities yeah
it's uh uh um I've been to the town
um I can't think of it off top my
Harrison Harrison Arkansas yeah I
watched a video and I was like what
Google it Harrison Arkansas see uh I
think most people see that as the most
racist town uh in in the United States
is Harrison Arkansas Harrison Arkansas
I'll just I mean I mean all towns have
racism in it yeah racist right and it
was yeah yeah it was sorry the person
was holding a black lives matter sign
yeah and they were just and and and and
the experiment was is that they would
just hold the sign and see what would
happen I mean yeah they didn't say they
don't give a [__] the people were like
they don't give a [__] they were like
just [__] yell whatever oh man the
stuff that I saw in that video you know
the person again not saying the thing
they're holding the sign and they were
filming you know GoPro filming and
people were like you better not be here
when I get back if you are you're gonna
pay it's like whoa we're just gonna
openly threaten people's lives right now
like it was [__] insane to listen to
the things that people said just like
openly saying the n-word or saying this
or threatening them oh yeah lynching I'm
like what oh hell yeah
dude I I go back to my small town I bet
I bet I could I bet I could go in almost
any kind of restaurant there you
wouldn't have to wait more than 15
minutes and you'd hear the hard r at
least yeah half dozen times right now
especially in the world we live in
because that's all it is it's about
loving to hate yeah and I was telling
the audience this too because I grew up
with guns in our house that I don't
personally own any guns but my dad had
guns uh you know hunting guns but when I
was a kid like when we grew up on the
farm because I grew up in a town of 4
000 people but I grew up three miles
outside of town on a farm yeah like the
closest neighbor's like a half mile away
that's how that's how [__] you know I
didn't have neighbors I mean we've had
neighbors they were just along you
couldn't throw a rock at them because
they were so damn far away but the thing
is is that we left our house unlocked
when we weren't there when we were there
we had the the cars we kept the keys in
the cars and they were unlocked in the
driveway I mean all of our equipment
that had the keys in it because we
didn't have we weren't like oh we need
to get ourselves from our enemies in the
government like that's not why we had
well it's also one of those places where
you're like why would I ever try to
uh
uh like if I if I saw Farm like if I was
coming into town and I saw your farm and
I was like man there's not a place
nearby in terms of another house or
residence
and I was like oh gonna steal this car
or I'm gonna like break in there's like
nowhere to hide there is nowhere to run
to other than a large open field and
maybe like a barn maybe maybe a stack of
hay bales or something like that steal
this car and it's like dude I could sit
on my front porch and I can see where
you're going for the next mile you know
what you know what the thing that that
pissed us off the most is uh the farm
that was behind us it was like 450 acres
and there was a lot of fishing ponds
that they had stocked years ago and and
a lot of people wanted to fish in those
ponds because there was huge bass in
those ponds I mean huge bass because
they're old and uh and that's one thing
that that's one thing that we had to do
was make sure people weren't fishing in
our [__] ponds that's that's the only
that I mean that's the only thing I can
remember like you would probably get the
gun out and rack the shotgun just to
scare them off you know because they
were yeah because they were fishing in
your damn Pond right that's it but we
weren't like oh they're gonna steal our
team I mean we had a 13-inch TV that had
the buttons on the front of it like
literally it had zero one two three four
five six seven eight nine power volume
up and down menu that it was that old of
a TV that's the fact and we had bunny
ears on it until we got until we got
fired we got Prime Star yeah Prime Star
was
pre-directv type you know it's the small
dish
I don't know it's just [__]
ridiculous to think that the culture has
changed but here's how it's changed this
is in um I believe this let's see this
video is in Wisconsin uh so the Midwest
you know Wisconsin yep you know
Wisconsin pretty well spent spent many
many years up there yeah so this is
representing Mark pocon I believe I
think I think he represents a second
district
um they're trying
the Republicans are trying to like do
amendments and stuff up there and
Appropriations and they're really mad
they're really mad about a pride flag
that cost 25 literally they're holding
committee hearings and doing amendments
on 25 in appropriation who's who's is
somebody selling is the government
selling these no they bought I don't
know just listen it's worth a listen
because they're going to talk about drag
shows too that a grant that wasn't given
to drag shows and they're bitching about
it just listen think about me as your
colleague I told you the story about a
plowing guy okay firing the guy doesn't
want to plow my driveway whatever
but did I share with you when I used to
get the article when I first ran for
office where they wrote dead over your
face and sent it to you in the mail
or the time that when I wasn't out yet
left a gay bar and two people followed
me and beat me with a baseball bat until
I was bloodied unconscious and called me
this is what you guys do
by introducing amendments like this you
started on the trans stuff I understand
the conservative movement threw some
spaghetti on the wall and found that
most people didn't know someone who was
trans so it was easy to attack that
because there was a Fear Factor and then
it slid to you don't like cloth Pride
flags all right fine ridiculous but
somewhat harmless and then you said you
can't discriminate against someone who
believes marriage is between a man or
woman even though the law says
differently that's just absurd but
harmful this is spitting on every single
person who is lgbtq plus but also our
allies and others because it's a
slippery slope you went from attacking
the trans Community to now affecting
everybody in the community and this the
next slippery slope is who's next
okay so that's not the full clip that I
was looking for we're gonna go back but
that's that's uh that's I mean that's a
good question and that's something that
we've always talked about League I told
you the story the fact of like what is
next you know when Roe v Wade was
overturned people like that's just
abortion stop [__] complaining we
said on the show no we're you know there
was just an ad that was released this
past weekend that was literally making
fun of the thing that we joked about
which was they're gonna come after
contraception they're going to take your
condoms your birth control whatever
might be they're gonna take it away and
they're trying it and they're trying to
again it's one one little thing to know
how far they can go so they can go a
little bit further and a little bit
further and a little bit further
and even though Republicans have not
found Roe v Wade or anything on women's
rights to be a winning subject a winning
platform as we've seen in local
elections representatives and also
things that are brought forward
and now when it comes to attacking the
trans community
or using some BS reason about a website
that a person that is that this
designer never actually made it was all
it was all made up it was I mean they
didn't even make websites like never got
an email she never talked to this guy
the guy after the fact was like I've
never heard of this thing in my life
I've never sent an email I'm straight
married and I also have my own design
company why the [__] would I hire this
woman to make it that's weird as [__]
it's all it's all projection it's all
this fear of a boogie man they're making
this [__] up why here's the clip that I
was looking for here's the same
representative talking about these drag
shows this it was a it was a state grant
that was given to drag shows okay they
gave State money to drag shows for
promotion
how egregious the problem is is that
well I'll let him explain thank you
madam chair I was just wondering if the
chair of the subcommittee would yield to
a question
um can you tell me on the the drag show
that was uh funded in Ecuador how much
was that
I have it here sure uh it's actually not
even on the web page it wasn't a lot of
money uh but it was a drag show uh as a
matter of fact if you like I just give
you this document I'm just asking you
and I don't want to use all my time
after you can just answer the question
all right I believe that one in Ecuador
I believe was twenty thousand dollars
for one drag show for I don't know if it
was one or multiple but I have it here
and I can share it with you because I
think it was for 13 drag shows and it
was for two workshops and it was for a
two minute video for twenty one thousand
dollars so probably under a grand for a
drake show if it was funded that way
correct here it is yeah does that sound
reasonable what I just said uh again I
have it here I've I've I haven't looked
at this document in detail in for a
little while but but uh it is all here
it's also on the internet again I do my
own I'm not sure how funding drag shows
abroad helps our national security
interests sure uh which is what we're
discussing and remember
I heard that I heard that they were not
been doing it here it is sure I'm gonna
take back my time and just one more
question was that rescinded by any
chance that Grant
this may have been pulled uh okay wait
wait so we didn't spend twenty one
thousand dollars on 13 drag shows two
workshops in a two minute video so a
thousand dollars oh that's why you
should not be upset that we're not
funding drag shows if they're not doing
it why is it a big deal to not fund it
that's not fun to take back my time so
this is interesting so you're worried
about a grant that never occurred which
you could have told us up front no it
was rescinded it was rescinded so anyway
The Pride flags that you're so
passionate about uh cost somewhere
between if you look online 25 to 40
dollars we are micromaging pedantically
dealing with this budget at such a small
level in order to you to make certain
people in your base happy and in your
caucus happy who've built a brand around
hate so in doing so you're doing the
silliness of determining whether 25
Flags can come out of the Appropriations
budget that is pedantic and crazy quite
honestly that that's what we're debating
we have a drought genocide child labor
child marriage disease famine
malnutrition droughts
all sorts of things that we could be
dealing with and what we are dealing
with
is talking about a 25 flag or a
rescinded Grant
now let's just be honest among friends
that this isn't for Appropriations
purposes we're doing this because you're
desperate to get the votes together and
you've got some folks who need this sort
of stuff who are still not going to vote
for it by the way I'm willing to bet any
of you on whether or not we get the 12
bills done by the way uh through the
floor completely but let's just admit
what we're doing
a rescinded grant that would have been
good information to share during your
remarks and a 25 flag is hardly the
level that we should be debating here in
the Appropriations Committee and just
for the record in World War II uh there
was a show called This is the Army 113
performances on Broadway raised 45 000
the first night for the Army Relief Fund
10 million dollars overall with um oh
guess what soldiers in drag no and then
they did a movie on this called This is
the Army against it wait for it your
friend mine Ronald Reagan
Missouri this is the Army about the
soldiers doing drag that raised 10
million dollars for uh the Army Relief
Fund by the way the highest grossing
movie at the time three times Wizard of
Oz had gotten at that point now so for
all the the worries about I think you
said the focus on foreign threats that
we're dealing with a pride flag is not a
foreign threat a drag show is not a
foreign threat Ronald Reagan is not a
foreign threat but having this kind of
rhetoric on the floor so you can get
people who want to Pander and fundraise
to certain aspects of your base is a
threat to this democracy so I just want
to put it out there I didn't plan on
debating but every time you put this
stupid crap up that has nothing to do
with Appropriations
I'm gonna stand up and say something I
yield back
I hope I hope he continues to stand up
and say something this is U.S
representative uh no this is a United
States House Representative Mark pocan
of the second district of Wisconsin
God damn
I'll tell you what that's uh that's a
hell of a hell of a little clip there oh
yeah I'm following absolutely owning
speaking of speaking of Representatives
yeah you got something here uh yeah
okay looks it looks like uh Marjorie
Taylor green is putting up a new poster
outside of her office no [__] let's see
yeah when is this let's see here this is
Marjorie Tate let's see
whoa wait a minute
that seems real to me
I mean she's making a statement and I'm
gonna take her I'm gonna take her on a
word so she thought captured for all of
you uh listening to the audio version
here not seeing the video
um this is one reason why you want to
come subscribe to the YouTube channel
the Tony Michaels podcast that way you
can catch these little moments that you
can't hear you can only see but it's
Marjorie Taylor green hanging up a sign
and this is totally real wink wink
I remember hanging up a sign that says I
[__] I don't know man it looks pretty
real to me it looks really I do not even
have to question no not at all I don't
think so I think this is yeah you can
just go ahead and say this is totally
100 real this is legit legit yeah it's
real speaking of Marjorie Taylor green
videos
[Music]
Marjorie Taylor green bragging about how
great Joe Biden is as president of the
United States even comparing him to the
great FDR and saying continuing the
Great Society that FDR started LGB
LBJ wear his balls hang
nuts excuse me his nuts he wouldn't call
me yes it's you know right right near
the bunghole right yeah right as he and
I'm not making that up that's what he
said LBJ said bunghole brunhole right
but what LGBT
llbj continued
Joe Biden is trying to finish it I
cannot believe that she said that [__]
the way she said it because they did
exactly I mean people online and US
included were like well this is an ad on
its own oh clearly clearly man it was an
ad clearly it was an end and boom
outshits the ad like not even 24 hours
later all they did was they're like yeah
let's put some footage on here it's just
her voice it's her voice
saying these things and they're not even
taking it out of context other than she
thinks this stuff is bad obviously the
rest of the country is gonna go well
that that's that's that's that's
Margaret Taylor green Lauren bobert
Thomas Massey exactly James Comer all of
these idiots who say these things out
loud and you're like you do realize
right you're you're not making the like
you're you're making the complete
opposite point right right it's like Don
Jr being like I don't snort uh cocaine
it's like yeah we know [__] right I
thought he said I don't snort all Coke
all cocaine all of it I mean all of it I
share it some sometimes but here's
Marjorie Taylor green endorsing Joe
Biden right here endorsement it is let's
let's listen Joe Biden had the largest
public investment in Social
infrastructure and environmental
programs that is actually finishing what
FDR started that LBJ expanded on and Joe
Biden is attempting to complete programs
to address education Medical Care Urban
problems rural poverty Transportation
Medicare Medicaid labor unions amazing
and he still is working on it awesome
[Music]
oh my God and he's still working on it
because that's what a good president I'm
sorry that's what a great president does
right and you know what he's even
running for re-election so Marge I can't
wait to hear this ad on the radio or see
this ad in commercials you know what's
going to be amazing you know what's
better than the commercial itself
that it's gonna you know it pisses her
off oh yeah I don't I don't talk about
Joe Biden much on this show I don't
tweet at the president
I don't quote tweet his [__] most the
time or the white house but I did this
one I was like hell yeah dark Brandon's
still at work
oh my God what a [__] idiot what a
[__] wow I I literally they were
writing this like they were writing
because she had it written down she was
reading that [__] oh yeah no she was
like she was like okay so yeah
she had she had a little piece of paper
and she was like okay hold on she's like
okay so so Joe Biden uh he's is
continuing to work on things that FDR
did and expanding what LBJ did and he's
still working on it he's he's working on
it he's still working work well you know
what's funny is they were sitting in a
room somewhere writing this [__] and
they're like okay what what do we really
want to bash here well let's go after
Medicare okay okay Medicaid we'd take
that we hate education we [__] hate
it yeah
[Music]
how dare he try to try to Stamp Out
rural white poverty okay let's write
that down like what I just [__] I just
love how she has the glasses like like
there are there are literal
teleprompters at this uh this Nazi
convention okay she decides to pull out
a paper and go let me tell you about Joe
Biden okay go Biden Joe Joe here you
know what where is this I'll pull out
hold on one sec I'll even do the whole
thing I got the mic here look Joe
uh hold on there we go okay attention
Joe Biden Joe Joe Biden
um turns out he's doing all of these
things to help uh the American people
and uh and I gotta say
um I'm not I'm not a fan of it
um I hate Americans I mean I hate it
well I I hate anyone who's not white
this is what I meant to say classic
um but I also don't like uh helping
anyone that isn't me
um I love using uh insider trading
knowledge to advance my financial
position thanks covid
um I also love to cheat on my husband
though I claim to be a Christian
and now I'm dating um rsbn right wing
commentator Brian Glenn and I'm also a
fan of uh forgi I mean fellatio I mean
uh Forgiato blow the rap artist I was
just in a music video with
um but anyway back to Biden Biden is as
the literal devil he is Satan
um and uh and I hate the fact that he's
uh you know kind of bringing it back I
hate the fact that he's helping uh
people in America because that's not
what we're supposed to do
mic drop for Marjorie Taylor green on
the Joe Biden ad perfect oh my God she
did such a good job with that ad
she did a great job yeah you know I will
admit uh Big Stuff fan here says again
I'm not having to look at the paper
enough uh I I know I know God forbid I
just I just wing it here uh right wing
it here uh and I should have I should
have looked at the paper more you know
you know who's doing horrible though you
know he's doing horrible at their
message
Ron DeSantis oh my God this [__] guy
can't get it together listen Donald
Trump announces yesterday or day is
yesterday he said I'm
I'm getting indicted I'm getting it done
again
I'm Thrice I got three wise and three
indictments he's really on the three
train I guess
and you think Ron DeSantis would throw a
punch right
like really throw a punch like come on
are you kidding me are you kidding me
uh he's such a he's such a little punk
ass [__] let's let's look at him from
the profile he's just like
it is it's pathetic
I mean thank you for having me this is
the best interview I will ever have this
week
well let's listen to what Ron has to say
about Trump getting indicted for the
third time let's see if no no not
officially and not officially indicted
well yeah but he's gonna be no I know no
I know I don't know somebody somebody
asked if he was but that's what that's
what the question is yeah yeah yeah I've
seen the official indictment we know
there's a third one there's gonna be a
[__] fourth one a fifth right it's
gonna be a [__] Star Wars yeah it's
probably nine by the end of this listen
I I would imagine I would imagine that
the American people are eventually going
to go wait he was arrested again why
don't they just lock him up for good
like how many times do they have to
arrest him like literally that's what
the American I'm telling you people out
there that don't watch this [__] that
don't pay attention that's what they're
hearing Trump arrested okay two months
later Trump arrested like what the [__]
I thought he was already arrested right
like three months later Trump arrested
again Trump rearrested like why are they
rearresting him why don't they just
stick him in the jail sell and not let
him lose because any other normal person
right would immediately be held
and Donald Trump when people like oh
there's two tiered yeah it's two-tier
man yeah [__] Rich wealthy powerful
people yeah Donald Trump is a recipient
right he is not on the the the the side
that is holding them you know is
actually holding them accountable
you know the charges come the indictment
comes
but he gets to go home he gets to go
home to Mar-A-Lago and fundraise off
that and grift off people and this and
that and use these uh these Town Halls
to whine and complain like a little
[__] that he is but anyone else oh my
God anyone else would never reality
winner you remember reality winner [__]
one page one page and they locked her up
immediately but let's what see what what
meatball says here about
um his pudding buddy Donald Trump
getting getting possibly more than
likely for sure he's he's gonna get
indicted again see what he has to say
about it breaking news today uh your
Chief competitor the front runner right
now uh Donald Trump says he was informed
that he is the target of special counsel
Jack Smith's investigation into efforts
to overturn the results of the 2020
election and Mr Trump has until Thursday
to report to the grand jury if Jack
Smith has evidence of criminality should
Donald Trump be held accountable okay I
want to say here Jake Capper feels
really uncomfortable
doesn't it give that sense and it's
almost like because Ronda santis is
doing the puppy dog thing where he's
like what hmm
and chick capper's like are you on are
you on cute puppy mode or something you
need to set yourself on presidential
candidate mode or something I don't know
what she's got like an earpiece and
someone's like stop moving stop tilting
your head and
uh [__] [__] weirdo he's such a
[__] weirdo man even Jake Tapper is
kind of creeped out here it looks like
by the skin suit that is Ron DeSantis
but let's hear the answer to the
question let's see what Ron has to say
so here's the problem uh this country is
going down the road of criminalizing
political differences I think that's
wrong Alvin Bragg stretched the statute
in Manhattan to be able to try to Target
Donald Trump most people even people on
the left acknowledge if that wasn't
Trump that case would not have likely
been brought against the normal civilian
and so you have a situation where the
Department of Justice FBI have been
weaponized uh against people they don't
like and the number one example of that
happened to be against Donald Trump with
the Russia collusion uh that was not a
legitimate investigation that was being
done all right all right Ron shut the
[__] I know why he can't say that right
[__] up you know why he can't go after
Trump right yes I do but go ahead tell
the audience it's it's it's very simple
but also very [__] dumb the reason
that Ron DeSantis will not go after
Trump and attack him and actually say
those things because he'll use the
DeSantis war room to make those bigoted
or other attacks against uh Donald Trump
the reason that Rhonda Santos won't say
this in an interview is because he is so
desperate to cling on to any remaining
Trump supporter that might possibly vote
for Rhonda santis right that's on the
fence like
I could vote for you instead he is so
desperate to hold on to any of those
people who are in the middle between
those two as possible candidates he
cannot risk losing any more people he's
got Vivek Rama Swami on his [__] back
he's gonna Leap Frog him to just prop up
Trump I can't believe Vivek is gonna
jump him in these [__] fake ass polls
they're really gonna do that they're
going to have him but again he can not
say anything bad about Trump he has to
play it safe he has to agree he has to
have and on these topics of the
weaponization of the federal government
it's called doing a crime you commit a
crime you do the time anyone else in
this position any other Republican
anyone else who who would understand the
facts of the case somebody committed a
crime they're charged indicted
they are now going to you know be
responsible for potential time that they
do right whatever whatever they're
charged with whatever the jury comes up
with whatever but again innocent until
proven guilty though we all know that
Trump's guilty
um
guilty the best guilty you've ever seen
the best guilty you've ever thrown in
many documents
greatest guilty of all time and then but
yeah Rhonda Santos is so desperate he
can't risk losing any more people he's
losing veterans now he's losing anyone
that was in Florida that might have
possibly considered him he has somehow
impressively really alienated himself
from the Republican Party there's a guy
on YouTube he's got this show every
weekday they do like two hours he said
this months ago I forget what his name
is he's got like two first names I
forget what this guy's name is he uses
the f word a lot but he said there's
like three months ago that Rhonda Santos
was totally [__] destroyed his
political career absolutely destroys
political because there's no way in hell
that he was going to be able to attack
Trump on the things that he needed to
attack Trump to to I don't know win a
presidential election it's almost like
there's a guy who said that [__] and
it's almost like it's almost like that
guy told Ron to get in the race right
before Donald Trump was indicted in the
Manhattan D.A and started attacking him
on that point it's almost like someone
said that Rhonda sanctimonious
it should have totally Come Out Swinging
but he's got those
little tiny little tiny pudding punches
I think casmo has it right here Michael
Tony I think that's yes
Miguel Anthony yes I think that's who it
was I think that's who it was yeah yeah
[__] around DeSantis the other thing
about this this interview when he says
this about oh they're they're trying to
criminalize political differences when
he says that he's projecting because
he's literally in Florida
criminalizing political differences he's
literally doing that right now as the
governor of Florida he's criminalizing
political differences when he's
stripping books and making sure teachers
can't teach children uh history Ron
doesn't like when you disagree
what does he do he throws you in the
jail
Rhonda santis dude he's a piece of [__]
that's the worst Sesame Street song I've
ever heard but it gets to the point you
know the lesson the lesson is learned
what he's doing right exactly lyrics to
it but he's a [__] piece of [__] man
the word of the day is meatball
and the letter of the day is f for
fascist
oh God damn so there's a lot uh going on
with um
the labor strikes so we got we got we
got the writers strike we got SAG we got
UPS it looks like we're gonna have the
airline
um with the with the on-air uh staff on
the planes I can't why can't I
um
flight attendants that's it no well
flight attendants I don't [__] fly I
don't fly I don't fly I'm telling me get
up in the sky go for a fly you know I I
stay on the ground I got feet anyways it
looks like they're gonna strike too
everybody striking everybody's striking
everybody striking dude but
um there's been a lot of videos but a
great one is Trey Crowder here Trey
Crowder did a great job at describing
um why why it is so important that
people are striking in this country and
it's not just it's not just because it's
writers and and sag the actors and it's
UPS drivers and now it's going to be
flight attendants brain fart
um the flight attendants these are major
industry trees well you know that's the
the funniest part is well [__] it I'll
just I'll just let I'll let you talk
about it what's the summer of the strike
babe and things are heating up out here
for labor that's right everybody knows
that sag and the rider's Guild my two
unions have Hollywood on its names but
they're not alone around the country
you've got nurses fast food workers
hotel workers Auto Workers UPS employees
all taken to the streets and demanding
with one voice you paid me and it's long
overdue for too long these bosses these
corporate overlords have been using
record profits to buy another volcano
layer or golden plated sex boat all the
while telling the people that do the
work that affords in those luxuries but
they should just shut up and be grateful
to have a job at all they're not even
trying to hide their contempt anymore
last week the Hollywood bosses publicly
said their goal was to starve us out to
make it where people start losing their
homes and then we'll see then we'll know
our place yeah good job kicking that
Hornet's Nest before shoving it straight
up your ass we'll see how that works out
for you okay they say that they say
things like that and then say that
workers are bringing reasonable they're
like these workers they just overvalue
Their Own Worst to the company right
well I saw a headline yesterday that
said if UPS workers go on strike it'll
cost the U.S economy seven billion
dollars seems like those workers must be
pretty important only there's a way we
can put a value on what they're worth
right not for nothing if all those
workers kept doing their jobs but the
CEO of UPS left off for a month pretty
sure the trucks would still run on time
okay the CEOs they think they believed
that they deserved these Untold Millions
right they think that they're
irreplaceable really you don't think we
could find somebody else to smoke cigars
and make people cry they're trying to
replace all of us and they think they're
irreplace for what what do y'all do you
don't make anything you don't deliver
anything you don't write anything what
do you do and they would say oh we do
plenty of stuff you know we compare
metrics analyze Trends assess risk oh
yeah that sounds like a whole bunch of
computer stuff to me just do your job
how about that I think they can handle
it I think a robot can handle green
light and a goddamn Goonies reboot you
know I'm not sure that the technology
exists for them to sexually harass all
the interns yet but I think we could
figure it out you know also if you you
can have a robot green light at Goonies
reboot but if you have a robot ride it
and cast it with a bunch of deep fakes
it's going to be a piece of [__] and
everybody knows that labor is
irreplaceable okay and wrist they love
to talk about risks where we assume all
the risk workers risk their lives their
health their future their families their
backs what do y'all risk company money
in a golden Parish you kiss my ass man
somebody in this equation does need to
learn their place and it ain't Labor All
right but they say to you they don't
matter they just can't afford it like
the company just cannot afford to meet
these demands how dumb do you think we
are you think we haven't seen what I've
been doing we think we think we haven't
noticed y'all getting fat off yearly
quarter billion dollar cakes and then
scraping the crumbs off the table for
the rest of us you've been pissing on
our heads and calling that trickle down
for decades and you didn't see this
coming how far did you you think you
could push people
well it's here the moment is here the
time is now and y'all better come to the
table and make this right because if you
don't the next time you check your watch
it's liable to be Pitchfork Thirty how
about that
pitch fork 38 man I mean it's true you
couldn't say it any better than what uh
Trey Tre trailer and spot on I mean out
here in L.A it is very much that you
know we've got two unions everything is
shut down right there are people who
might go out and scab and they'll be
[__] black so be blacklisted from the
industry entirely uh but anyone who's a
part of those unions or who who is a
non-union uh performer and they go and
they take the job of someone who is
Union [__] it dude you better enjoy the
very short time that you have in that
role that you've been given because
after that job is is replaced by someone
who is Union or who is talented or who
has a name and billing to them
you're gonna be out on the [__]
Street you will have you will have
compromised on the very values and
ethics that that what unions support
because you decided to go in for a quick
buck and there's influencers online who
are doing this and there's other people
who are trying to take advantage of it
do not do that you will [__] yourself
over in the process of a quick buck
and I do not feel sorry for any of those
people
it's [__] [__] and that's just
one industry and and it's going to be
several Industries here because
um not only not only are these workers
looking around at the the rough deal
that they got like the the flight
attendant deal I guess that contract was
done in 2019 so that was pre-pandemic so
that contract doesn't even have what
what workers would think about when you
think about essential worker essential
right essential workers
which to be all honest with you the
writer and sag Union is essential what
the [__] would you have done during the
pandemic if not watch content
that writers and actors produced and
made the other crazy part about this is
that a lot of people in this country
who don't understand unions but also
don't understand some of these
industries are like why are the actors
striking they're rich aren't they like
[__] most of them uh Kevin Bacon
had a great video
well actually it was uh
um who was it
damn
uh but yeah I can I can explain this one
really cool well well it was Sean Austin
and he said that 87 of the members in
the SAG
Union don't earn 26 000 that they need
to qualify for healthcare let's put that
think about that in perspective right
now
87 of that Union's members of the SAG
Union do not earn the 26 000 threshold
that they need to earn to get their
benefits of Health Care through that
Union to qualify for it they don't
receive that
87 so what is the union if you can't
make enough money to get your union
[__] benefits right so so to to and
again they're not negotiating how much
money they can make that's part of it
but they're also negotiating their
[__] working rights and what the [__]
what the [__] they expect when they work
for these Studios I mean I've been I've
been following the last few days in
terms of negotiations and you know what
what sag has put forward which is
I mean some of the stuff is
is not
it's not [__] rocket science it's
like uh oh we should give like stunt
performers residuals right we should
give uh and we should make sure that
people who have to you know little
things like oh we have to make sure that
people who show up
uh on set and have to provide for their
own makeup they could be recompensated
like they they could be compensated uh
or or
um
uh they can have their expenses covered
we can and the biggest thing
that sag and the writers are coming
forward with is this fear of what Ai and
Technology will do to replace them
background actors having their faces
scanned so you don't have to pay
background actors I mean there are some
people in the industry who make their
living off of background acting they're
the people who are moving around who
know their place their Mark they go from
pointing right they're in all the
[__] movies yeah they're in all the
like they're in all of them because
they're so the way that so the way that
it works is you could have
um there are several ways that you can
get it to the Union right you can work a
you can work a sag job and then you
become SAG eligible and then there's a
time period you have a 30-day period
once you're like all right you have to
join the union after this point you know
there's background actors you if you're
a featured background actor you can you
can get three vouchers to become part of
the Union
if you
um are someone who works a sag job you
can also Taft Hartley in which basically
is like boom you're you're in you're
you're now uh part of the Union once you
pay your dues
these are people again 87 do cannot
afford these things you have
Millionaires and this and that but but
think about that think about the number
twenty six thousand dollars now 15 20
years ago that's not a bad number maybe
for here in Missouri but twenty six
thousand dollars ain't gonna buy you
[__] and 87 aren't making twenty six
thousand dollars
so so so this idea that people are like
oh well these actors just being greedy
no the actors that make all the [__]
money the ones that get the big
contracts that don't need the union to
negotiate their contracts because they
got the big names and they're the big
stars they're out fighting for the
little guy
they're out fighting for the little guy
get it [__] straight these actors
that are making big contracts that are
standing on the streets like Kevin Bacon
Kevin Bacon don't need no [__] money
he knows that he said it he said it in
the interview he said basically I don't
need no [__] money but I'm here for
them because without them I don't exist
Kevin Bacon doesn't exist without those
[__] and it's solidarity it's
standing in solidarity of [__] mean
something and it should mean something
in this country it should mean something
to stand up for the little guy when when
when that when your career was blasted
off in the outer space
and you got wealthy you should stand up
for the little guy you should speak up
for the little guy and make sure they
get theirs too that's what should happen
and it's going to happen more than just
this industry and just ups and and the
flight attendants I mean this is gonna
this is gonna compound because I believe
and I told you guys this before that the
audience that that the pandemic taught
American something that we are [__]
essential they [__] need us more than
we need them
you goddamn right they need us more than
we need them and they better [__]
start acting like it and the one the one
thing I want to uh the sicko fit says
the Oppenheimer cast walked off the
carpet in solidarity so I want to clear
something up
yes in solidarity but also the rules of
the union state that you can't promote
so like not only is it's not just uh we
can't have people on set working a
production like if there was the
Deadpool 3 movie like no one can no one
can work anymore you've got 160 000
members of the Union no one can work and
everyone who has a movie coming out this
week you know or the following weeks
until this strike is over no one if the
agreement is no one as an actor or a
writer can promote their their work they
can't promote their shows they can't
promote their films they can't promote
anything that's happening and in
addition to that what I find hilarious
is that the last time
well here what I find hilarious about
this whole thing is that Republicans
people just like you know
average [__] Blue Collar Republicans
they're the very same ones who are like
[__] Wall Street they're making money
off our backs you have to pay it back we
have to be the ones who bail them out
this is [__] [__]
and today when you see the very same
thing happening the exploitation of
Labor and talent and experience by
corporate overlords by people who are
CEOs who manage and pull the strings
here and there but believe that they
earn millions of dollars because they
run a studio or an industry or something
like that
now
these people that were like [__] the
banks and [__] these people we have to
bail them out are the same people who
are like oh no no general labor you
shouldn't be paid you shouldn't get a
minimum wage that actually
adjusts for inflation you shouldn't have
protection or health care or any of
these other benefits as America as a
just as a right that you should have
so when I see stuff that's happening
right now the strikes all these things
it is a wake-up call for many people and
I wouldn't be surprised if some people
begin to open up and and awaken right
because
just like in that other clip about uh
the production that was done with Ronald
Reagan guess who the last time now
there's a there's a little caveat here
the last time that the writers Union and
the and the wga in Sag were on strike
together with
1960 or 1963 or something like that
do you know who the president of sag was
at that time the the pro-union was it a
drag queen it was a drag queen also
known Ronald Reagan ah but as soon as
Ronald Reagan got into the White House
guess what he did
what did he do he [__] over the unions
oh man so so when people try to argue
all unions are bad news no no no you had
the father of Reaganomics trickle-down
Reaganomics or as as Trey says you know
these CEOs and and corporate leaders
pissing on us but telling us it's
trickle-dynamic economics it's true it's
all trickle up man everything feeds up
like a [__] pyramid scheme when it
comes to our our capitalist Society in
America
but when Republicans want to talk about
oh man good old days we have this and
this and this well yeah fine let's talk
about Ronald Reagan yeah fighting on
behalf of actors and writers to make
sure that they got the things that they
deserved you tried to go to the White
House was like ah [__] these unions you
try to go find anywhere that gives you a
pension nowadays an actual pension a
real [__] pension you ain't gonna
find it and find you a Republican that
didn't the scumbag hey I got a
republican scumbag I want to show you
okay I got a transition we're gonna go
to this yeah yeah we're gonna go to the
fake electors here no oh baby a real
American Union yeah right the fake
elector the TR the fake Trump electors
Union there's like that many of them
there oh my God there is that many Trump
criminals that are gonna go to prison
for this [__] that they could
probably start a union do you know yeah
they probably could son of a [__] did
you did you son of a [__] they could
probably start a [__] Union I mean
they God damn there's enough of them
there's got to be how many how many how
many get can you can you see if Google
tells how many
um people were convicted of crimes
because of January 6 already can you see
if it'll tell us well there's like what
over I mean over a thousand I think yeah
right but now but now we've got 16 more
felony indictments in Michigan for Trump
yeah these are have you heard have you
heard the narrative that people like
Jack prostate are trying to push oh I
love this grandma and Grant you're
you're gonna put grandma and grandpa in
jail or get your goddamn right we are
dude you got that right we are yeah yeah
Grandpa murders somebody we're gonna put
him in [__] jail that's how it's
gonna work commit a crime you do the
time it's really easy like it's not it's
not that difficult it's literally like
one plus one equals two you know you
know what else isn't difficult
that they they planned on doing this
this is Stephen Miller you can see all
the the Christmas the Christmas behind
you know that we're on Christmas Fox
News has to have Christmas everywhere in
like in in October November December and
then into January because they got
boners for Christmas or something but
here is here is Stephen Miller
an advisor to the president of the
United States at the time Donald Trump
this is December uh of of 2020. Erie is
on Fox News listen to what he says about
alternative electricity if it see if it
sounds like what these indictments were
the only date in the constitution is
January 20th so we have more than enough
time to right the wrong of this
fraudulent election result and certified
Donald Trump as the winner of the
election as we speak today an alternate
slate of electors in the contested
States is going to vote and we're going
to send those results up to Congress
this whoa whoa what did he say did he
say there's gonna be
uh an alternative slate of electors you
know what's funny about this is there's
emails where they're like we shouldn't
call them fake electors yeah like
because that makes it sound illegal so I
mean Stephen Miller's like so we're
gonna send up some Frank I mean uh
alternative electors you know
um we're gonna make sure that we can
steal this election well I mean he
literally I'm a Nazi
let's let's see what the Nazis says here
let's see what gerbils says here this
will ensure that all of our legal
remedies remain open that means that if
we win these cases in the courts that we
can direct that the ultimate state of
electors be certified the state
legislatures in Georgia Wisconsin
Pennsylvania can do the same and
likewise Congress has that opportunity
as well to do the right thing now I've
been saying I've been saying what the
[__] I've been saying for a while now
that if if funny will is the Fulton
County D.A in Georgia indicts these
State electors that will probably see a
waterfall of indictments out of what did
I say did I say Pennsylvania Arizona
Wisconsin what was the other one I said
I swore hey can you can you go back and
get the tape and see if I sent Michigan
I said Michigan and then yesterday in
the afternoon
bam all 16 of them I think there's like
six and all and all of them is it six
felony counts it's six felony counts
something like that I just I just
remember remember reading all the
comments I kept laughing yesterday too
where was like here are the facts these
people tried to commit a felon they they
tried to overturn the election by
writing on a [__] napkin uh Trump won
Trump won Trump is the winner it's like
shut the [__] up you idiots all you
elderly people who were so gullible
because you wanted things to be back how
they used to be AK you could say the N
word with the hard r that is who you are
all these people who are under Stephen
Miller this [__] Nazi over here
who loves to try to overthrow the
government any way possible I mean the
guy was the architect between distant oh
my God and Kevin says Dracula Dusty
Miller
but Stephen Miller I mean is an absolute
piece of [__]
um he's the architect behind separating
the families and the children at the
border at the southern border I mean
this is the guy who in many ways was
he had his grubby little hands and all
the different [__] that's the the mo the
worst parts of the Trump Administration
if you can imagine that
and the fact that he's on TV he's like
oh we got these alternative electors and
uh we hand selected these people these
elderly people I mean like some of these
people some of these people on Twitter I
mean one of the accounts like oh I'm
really waiting for them to come get me
now and I was like oh that tweet aged
very poorly well you know anyone
involved in State this state elector
scheme in any state has got to be [__]
in their drawers right now
um sickle fit says Nevada too yeah
Nevada but they weren't really
interested in that until they lost
Arizona Let's be clear on that they
thought they had Nevada and then when
they because they had Arizona when Trump
lost Arizona they really freaked out
that's when they went that's when
Grinnell went to Nevada if you remember
Rich Grinnell who was the interior
secretary he's a [__] scumbag too but
let's get back to these State electors
because
there's a reason why this is a different
case than the one in Georgia
the reason why it's a different case
than the one in Georgia is because in
Michigan
the law says because see that's the
thing the states get to decide
how to give their electoral votes right
they pass laws
to give those votes over to whoever wins
them right now in Michigan the electors
that go to Washington to the Electoral
College it's a really nice College they
got a really nice campus there
anyways they really tried to go look do
you remember that when the proud boys
went to look for the Electoral College
in in Washington DC and they couldn't
find that the college campus there do
you remember that anyways that's a thing
anyways in Michigan they have to do it
inside the building that is the business
of the capital so whatever it is the
capital at that moment which Michigan
has a capital right but let's say the
wind blew it down they would pick
another building they would deem that
the capital that's where you do in that
building it has to be done in a specific
building in Michigan
now I remember watching TV the day that
all all around the country they were
certifying these these electors right
they were doing in Georgia and Arizona
if you remember the governor of Arizona
was signing uh certifying them and Trump
was trying to call him at the same time
that was kind of weird but this is a
video of these electors who are now
charged with I think six different
felonies trying to get in the building
of the capital and the reason why
they're trying to get in the building of
the capital Gabe is because they have to
do that for it to be an actual legal
slate of electors
watch this this is [__] hilarious
they are here they're trying to do their
constitutional Duty I understand and
their constitutional Duty requires that
the vehicle finished
see that they have to be in the Senate
chamber they have to be in the capital
you know what's funny about this video
this person holding the Canada gloves
I was like
okay because I mean people people also
need to like so they state capital is in
Lansing which is in Michigan also
Michigan State University is
um but when I see
somebody wearing Canada gloves and the
Republican Party talks about how Canada
is the Socialist uh the apocalyptic land
and it's so communist because later on
you know we got the whole Trucking
[__] but you know what they were all
going to move to Canada when Barack
Obama became president you remember that
everyone was going to move to Canada
when some president comes in listen
listen I don't like the cold weather I
would never move to Canada especially I
mean if you move on the coast a little
bit better yeah right but still yeah
[__] Jesus Christ anyways let's let's
watch let's see if they can work their
way in here
if you have a problem
foreign
[Music]
boom so here's what happened I believe
I think the governor Michigan she was
like don't let those [__] in
that Capital do not let those [__]
treasonous pieces of [__] in the capital
I don't give a [__] who they say they
are they are not the electors they are
not
it's all right we're we're allowed to be
in there he's like dude I don't give two
shits man I'm not gonna make this
political all I know is I can't let you
in you dumbass
can you find me the video where they
recorded themselves
certifying themselves as electors it's
it that's gold too because that's the
crazy part is that when
when they were turned away from the
capital like you know what you know what
we'll do we'll just go somewhere else
and do this and we'll just certify this
so we're gonna go to an Applebee's well
they actually went to like a republican
headquarters or something which is even
more on the nose right and they all sit
around the table and they certify these
like yeah but in the document because
it's a state of electors from Michigan
it has to say it has to say that it was
certified
in the capital and it wasn't they
recorded themselves certifying it
outside the capital
and then they presented it as real which
is a reason why that they're charged
with felonies and it's the reason why
the Attorney General brought the
felonies counts to these people now I'm
not sure what took so long that's really
my question like why did it take so long
but I would imagine that
um the Attorney General of Michigan she
kind of has her case locked up tight
here because of the fact that they have
to be done inside the Capitol and these
people tried to forge official documents
and submit them as official documents
even though they knew they did not
certify them inside the capitol they
didn't give a [__] they didn't care how
they stole the election they just wanted
to steal it and and the video if you
find it is they played this video they
played this video on the January 6th
select hearing now during that hearing
during one of them where these people
were
sitting around the table which seemed
like in a small conference room and they
were they were pretending to certify
electors because that's really truly
what they were doing they were
pretending to because they really
weren't because in the state of Michigan
you have to be in the capital and that's
why they were trying so hard to get in
there now on the other in the other
states it's not like that Georgia it's
not like that they don't I don't think
it says in their laws that has to be in
the capital
so they have to go through a much more
uh extensive legal process to litigate
the felonies that would have happened of
them trying to overturn the Georgia
election and the Georgia electors that's
why Bonnie Willis it's taken so much
time it's it's a hell of a lot harder
to prove that case than this forgery
case where these people are just like
well we got to go to the Capitol so
let's go to the capital like no you
can't come in like oh we can't go in
there we have to certify him in there no
we don't we can just do whatever we want
we do whatever we want yeah sure okay
how'd that work out for you [__] around
and find out go ahead
and really honestly this is this is
nincompoop Nazi 101 right like if they
would have just had someone who knew
anything
it's almost like they didn't seek any
legal advice whatsoever it's almost like
they probably listened to emails from
Jeannie Thomas because that's the thing
I want to [__] know
Jeannie Thomas was in contact with a lot
of these states
yeah for these for these State electors
to be fraudulent and fake and I want to
know if Jeannie Thomas had any contact
with these 16 people that's what I want
to know I mean we know that she was
emailing Wisconsin well right in Arizona
right
right so the idea that to the realm of
possibility of her emailing people in
Michigan totally within that right I
would not be surprised
if she is somehow connected and again
this is someone who has benefited from
the ability to not have a recorded
deposition or at least one that would be
shown during the Jan six hearings right
they brought her in she talked she did
this thing that was it and then we never
heard anything we never knew anything
because some some information came out
about you know documentation of these
emails or these phone calls or these
these sexts that she sent to uh
to [__] Mark Meadows right uh
unresponsive from him to her but uh she
was like we gotta do this I mean she's a
crazy q and honor married to a Supreme
Court Justice who clearly is Tainted in
several ways doesn't recuse himself from
Jan six cases takes money from
billionaires
it's it's it's it's ridiculous we live
in a [__] messed up timeline man it
is a wild time to be alive I if you
can't find that I'm gonna go to uh James
Comer here because I'm gonna see what he
thinks I'm still looking but I'm gonna
see what he thinks of the possible Trump
indictment in the indictment of the 16
fake electors which I think James Comer
would be in favor of fake electors you'd
like yeah I really like those people and
I'm sure James Comer's like you can't
lock up old people for committing crimes
why why would you want to lock up old
people who commit crimes especially
crimes against elections dude I don't
care what the [__] happens you guys
broke the law right well not only that
these are the same [__] that
have been yelling election fraud since
November of 2020 and we find election
fraud and the the Arizona excuse me the
Michigan attorney general charges him
with felonies and you're like no don't
lock up Grandma for for election fraud
that's wrong okay all right it's sounds
like you're not in favor of election
fraud oh sorry I'm not sorry your
grandma is a gullible vulnerable piece
of [__] right like James Comer here
let's listen to what he thinks first
than that you've got a sitting president
attacking his potential rival in the
upcoming election former president Trump
says that he's the target of a January
6th grand jury investigation did Joe
Biden say that I swear to God I I
thought I thought I thought I thought he
was a reigned in court and I thought
that Jack Smith sent the target letter
it's almost like I missed that Joe Biden
Senate did Joe Biden send him a letter I
think Joe Biden sent him a letter and
they knew it was Joe Biden because there
were some uh chocolate chip ice cream
stains on I see so is so you're saying
that Jack Smith is just an AI version of
Joe Biden exactly exactly that makes
sense in this weird timeline okay let's
keep going with their lies
now people are expecting a third
indictment Congressman expecting Joe
Biden's doj
yeah he's the president to the point
where I don't think people are even
paying attention to the Trump
indictments I mean it's it's almost like
the Biden
re-election campaign continues to cry
wolf here I wouldn't be surprised if
they don't indict Donald Trump right
before I hit the gavel for this
Committee hearing today every time we
break big news
uh with respect to the Biden criminal
investigation Here Comes somebody to
indict Donald Trump to try to steal the
headlines okay if you don't know because
Donald Trump's being indicted the House
Republicans are have whistleblowers
whistleblowers I don't know if they're
Chinese spies too in in a Committee
hearing today because that's really
what's happening they're like
Donald Trump says if they can do this to
me then they can do it to you yeah if
they can do it to me they should be able
to do it to you the Republicans like
every single time we have a
whistleblower it's almost like we're
just using it as distraction from the
Trump indictments
this argument that they're like if they
could come after me they can come after
you that's how the law works man it's
always supposed to work if you commit a
crime you break the law yeah dude it's
called Law and Order they're gonna it's
gonna come after you right and obviously
those who are who are uh wealthy or
powerful or influential or what you know
white whatever you're gonna have that
two-tier justice system that Donald
Trump benefits from he's not in jail now
because the guy was a former president
he's Rich he has influence he's running
for [__] excuse I mean he's on that
upper second tier of justice is that
what you're saying I think that's what
you're saying I hear you saying that
that's what I hear you saying uh I
promised that I would give some clips of
the um
of the Trump interview but it really
wasn't that good it really wasn't he
didn't say anything new unfortunately he
never does really
but you know that's how it goes um but
there are some clips here that Aaron has
of this uh this hearing so why don't we
take a peek at that if you can't find
that uh that's gonna be article at the
fine I'll admit it I looked forward
earlier and I couldn't find I'm
I'm trying to find this yeah I'm trying
to find that clip and I I mean I found
I found the Michigan State Board of
canvassers they voted three to one to
certify Joe Biden so that's not it no no
no no they're in it they're inner it's
selectivity showed this video and it was
a video of them sitting around a table
and they're voting at a republican
headquarters or some [__]
here is here is that James Comer opening
this uh Committee hearing this morning
to distract from Donald Trump's
indictments and the indictments of the
Trump fake electors the 16 grandmas and
grandpas that we're gonna put in jail
for the rest of their five years of
their lives because they're criminals um
here he is opening the Committee hearing
this morning with his fake
whistleblowers just like they're fake
electors they have fake whistlers it's
kind of funny this is an important joint
effort that shows the American people
that accountability matters regardless
of your last name
hahaha
hi oh my God you can't you can't make
this Shameless [__] up man
oh my god did he did he just say
accountability no matter what your last
name is
yep he's got to be talking about Trump
right surely he's not though oh my man
it's the party of
[__] projection manual projection
Christ man
what a [__] bunch of dog turds these
are not serious people I'll say it again
these are not serious people
oh man he goes on to say oh we have a
Raskin clip here I'm sure we're asking
dunks him in the trash let's watch this
you know raskin's cool with his [__]
do-rags now right his bandanas that's
pretty sweet I'm not gonna I think Van
Zant gave him gave him this collection
of of headdress uh since he's had his I
think he's getting his chemo treatment I
think that's why yeah he just he had
finished remember he rang the bell
that's right that's right that's right
that's right yeah so now he's he's he's
still yeah he'll have a he'll have a
check you know checkups along the way
he'll have the one-year check up to make
sure he's in remission but yeah he's
still you know post-treatment now he's
you know able to well that's great a
somewhat normal life again I hope he I
hope he keeps continuing to wear these
bandanas to be quite honest yeah oh yeah
from now until forever makes him look
way cooler let's let's listen to Jamie
you're asking see what he has to thank
you Mr chairman good afternoon to the
witnesses
um I thought we might be here today on
the matter that the chairman declared
his top priority The Crusade to find
evidence of wrongdoing by President
Biden but now the majority's long
promised star witness turns out to be a
fugitive from American Justice in arms
trafficker indicted on eight Federal
Criminal felony counts in an
unregistered foreign agent for China who
tried to trade Chinese arms
for the majority anytime soon
well after the field SARS reports bank
records form 1023 we can conclude that
this Inspector Clouseau style quest for
something that doesn't exist has turned
our committee into a theater of the
Absurd in exercise and futility and
embarrassment
he dunks him in the trash in less than
50 seconds by the way that clip is 47
seconds you just don't need a lot of
time to talk about how much trash
Republicans are you just don't need a
lot of running it doesn't take a lot of
effort I mean you start with saying GOP
and you're like oh I know this is going
you know you do not need a long Runway
yeah to make your point about how shitty
they are uh oh here you go let's see
there's a couple other rants honestly
I'm surprised that Fox News played that
clip
but then again they they you know Fox
News has tried to play it somewhat safe
when it comes to this whole whistle you
because of defamation you didn't mean
yeah it's almost like they're they've
had to settle for almost 800 billion
with dominion and uh smartmatic is not
whole they're not they're they're like
no we're we're gonna we're gonna at
least get 800 billion out of you guys if
not the 1.6 or the one point yeah 1.6
that we uh 1.3 I forget which one it is
yeah
here's here's Jamie Raskin doing more
trash dunking at today's hearing we're
going to hear about wrongdoing
Biden who's guilty on tax charges and a
gun charge next week we'll hear about
the back and forth among investigators
prosecutors and a trumpet appointed U.S
attorney over a dozen people who spent
four years investigating the president's
son we'll hear about how they disagreed
on investigative steps and what criminal
charges to bring all normal stuff uh in
government investigations that doesn't
usually lead to a congressional hearing
but one thing you will not hear today
is any evidence of wrongdoing by
President Joe Biden or his
administration like every other tribe by
our colleagues to concoct a scandal
about President Biden this one is a
complete and total bust in fact the
ongoing case that the majority invites
invites us to interfere with today is
actually a striking illustration of the
success of the American system of
independent prosecutors operating under
the rule of law and outside the realm of
the kind of political influence my
colleagues are trying to exercise today
damn just straight straight does not
give two [__] God it's right he just
buries him uh with one page of words I
tell you what Jim you're asking is a
National Treasure yeah I mean well we
should cover it tomorrow but this whole
whistleblower x Hunter Biden thing is is
again folding it's unfolding hilariously
they've got they've got this guy oh wait
you're you telling me they stepped on a
rake again
right wing talking head is like breaking
the identity of whistleblower X who
claims that Hunter Biden should have
been charged with a tax felony has been
identified as Joseph Ziegler a gay
Democrat who worked in the IRS
investigative decision over the last
decade
turns out that whistleblower X has also
admitted in these these uh legal filings
another another argument raised related
to the WhatsApp messages remember those
messages that they're like these are
Hunter bidens and this and then oh yeah
yeah yeah the ones that are fake yeah
which Gary shapely included in his
testimony and he's like I can tell the
committee that I was the agent who
assisted summarizing and had included
the dimensions as part of the case
overall timeline
um they were summarized
which means that he did not investigate
them he did not look into them he
summarized the findings of what they
were and then we also found later on
that these messages were not real
because someone was like this photo
that's the [__] profile photo is from
after these text messages were sent
you guys are [__] boneheads man
they're [__] boneheads they're
boneheads and they're gonna continue to
be boneheads that's why we're gonna
continue to cover them because they're
[__] bone-ins right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube don't
forget to subscribe hit the [__] like
button I keep forgetting that I'm not
good at YouTube hit the like button the
like you're you know your what was that
you got the little graphics and you're
like don't forget to hit the you're so
good at I'm shitty and I'm like I just I
just started playing the thumbs up [__]
I just started putting that in uh yeah
it was great it was great you're good at
it you gotta smash that like button
smash subscribe button hit on that
notification Bell so you never miss
another episode
good so do that if you can while you're
here yeah what he said uh
just consider hitting the like button
before you would lead the broadcast that
would be fantastic please please do that
also you can watch it on Facebook every
single weekday at the Tony Michaels on
our Facebook page also on Twitch follow
us over there it's free free99 to follow
us on Twitch twitch.tv Tony Michaels
don't forget if you have your Amazon
Prime account linked to your Twitch
account don't forget to go resubscribe
you can find the directions at D Tony
michaels.com it's the fourth link down
it'll show you how to link your Amazon
Prime account and give us that one free
subscription you get with your Prime
account to your Twitch account giving us
a couple dollars each month but also
don't forget to resub that's how we get
it every single month also download
every single episode in the afternoon on
Apple's Spotify and Google you should
get the audio version every single
weekday download it every single weekday
damn it's Wednesday I was supposed to
have major o on today Major yeah I was
wondering what happened you had to
reschedule but tomorrow we have Fred
Wellman yeah we got Fred I was gonna try
to squeeze major in tomorrow too but I
think his schedule isn't gonna allow it
either so we might have we might have
major on next week it just our schedules
didn't
it didn't work out today it didn't work
out today he got busy with some stuff he
had to take care of which I understand
you know it's human your life you know
you got stuff you got to do that happens
so I I'm I I'm gonna work hard though to
get major back on we had Jess on
yesterday it was a great interview and
we'll have Fred on tomorrow Thursday
Thursday tomorrow is Fred Wellman so
don't miss that episode you're going to
want to come back tomorrow and also
Thursdays are when we do bonehead yep
that's right you vote for bonehead of
the week and then Friday you know you
know how it goes yeah we go you vote you
decide we go over bonus
so come back tomorrow we'll have Fred
Willman maybe major maybe maybe
I don't know I I it seemed like his
schedule was still kind of conflicting
there so but we'll have Fred Wellman at
the bottom of the hour and then we'll
vote for bonehead and we'll we'll knock
on the fascists like we do every every
single weekday same time same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass speaking